a book Banning Republican is very
quickly learning about the potentially
unintended consequences of his own
actions as a parent is now using the law
to try to get the Bible banned and I
have to tell you it makes a lot of sense
lgbtqnation.com reports book ban
lawmaker quote very sad and I don't know
why I find very sad to be funny that a
parent is using his law to ban the
sex-ridden Bible the parent said that if
lesser books have been banned then the
Bible which discusses infanticide rape
and bestiality is not appropriate for
kids I mean that it makes a lot of sense
a Utah parrot reads the article has
challenged the Bible under a state law
Banning pornographic or indecent
materials in schools it has been used to
remove books by mostly lgbtq plus and
black authors from shelves in a book
challenge submitted to Davis School
District the unnamed parent called the
Bible quote one of the most sex-ridden
books around according to the Salt Lake
Tribune
uh Utah state representative Ken Ivory
who sponsored HB 374 described the
request as a political stunt that would
rain drain School resources there was a
purpose to the bill and this kind of
stuff it's very unfortunate now of
course that's true the purpose of the
bill was not to actually ban all of this
type of content it was only to ban the
content that this guy doesn't like and
that is fundamentally what this is all
about and if we are to say let's apply
their standards the Bible must be bad
that's the reality now I'm not out there
advocating for anything to be banned but
if these are the standards graphic
descriptions of sexual activity
one example is of course Song of Solomon
7 1-9 where a woman describes her
Lover's body in sensual detail it's
basically a romance novel several
stories in the Bible are just filled
with explicit sexual content rape incest
Genesis 19 Angels save lot and his
family from the destruction of Sodom and
Gomorrah lot offers his virgin daughters
to the men to be raped in exchange for
their safety edgy doesn't really quite
cover that storyline I must say Ezekiel
23 20 graphic description of Two Sisters
engaging in sexual activity with
multiple partners Genesis 38 the story
of judah's son put to death by God for
wickedness and right before he dies he
engages in sexual activity with his
daughter-in-law who is disguised as a
sex worker
folks if this is actually the standard
the content and not whether it's
Christian content or black content or
whatever then the Bible must be banned
of course that is not the point of these
bills I'm sure you understand but they
want there to be a special status for
the Bible and I believe that if we have
these standards they should apply to all
reading materials Bible included